we have a lot of people on stage today
uh first off uh Globe minister of Health
um through the phone line uh or Zoom um
minister of
Transportation
affairs
from the public health agency will have
brief remarks after which I will take
question first on the floor and then via
Zuma ministers you have the floor
good morning
before starting good morning everyone
say that my thoughts are with everyone
who's been affected by Hurricane Fiona
Avant kamase
before beginning I'd like to say that my
thoughts are with everyone who has been
affected by Hurricane Fiona nationally
covid-19 weekly case counts have
increased slightly over the past week
which may be an early sign of resurgence
Regional variation remains with some
indicators such as Wastewater signals
also showing local Resurgence in some
areas while deaths are decreasing and
ICU numbers remain low numbers of people
in hospital are slow to decline and
remain elevated
with contact rates increasing and more
time spent indoors this fall we could
see continued growth of this trajectory
however we are going into this fall and
winter season with a very different
scorecard we now have a significant
advantage in terms of infection and
vaccine acquired immunity as well as
having bivalent vaccine formulations
that can further bolster our protection
at the same time we need to be mindful
of our vulnerabilities since we know
that immune protection decreases over
time
if it has been six months or longer
since an infection or your last vaccine
dose anyone 12 years or older and
eligible for a covid-19 booster can step
up to increase their protection keeping
up to date with covid-19 vaccines is
particularly important for individuals
at high risk for severe outcomes
bivalent covid-19 vaccines which Target
more than one strain of covid-19 are
expected to provide stronger and broader
protection
protecting our health starts with
keeping all of our recommended vaccines
up to date and adding layers of personal
protection including hand washing
wearing masks and poorly ventilated
indoor or crowded settings and staying
home via symptoms to prevent spreading
infection to others
remains low it is dropping very slowly
and remaining high in other cases taking
into account that we are spending more
time in the fall indoors
we would believe that there will be a
continued Rising figures
but our scorecard is very different from
what existed a year ago we have a point
of view that is been driven about by the
light of what we have learned from a
vaccinations and especially the bivalent
vaccine that provides greater protection
we are aware of our vulnerabilities
nonetheless and we know that immune
protection does decline over time if you
were infected or if you received your
most recent vaccination six months ago
or more you are able to get a Top-Up of
the booster this to keep your
vaccination against
this is particularly important for
persons who have a greater risk of
serious complications than the bivalent
vaccine is able to protect you against a
variety of strains
to protect our health we have to
continue to protect our health on a
daily basis according to our personal
needs for example wash your hands wear a
mask in indoors spaces or if there is
poor ventilation or where there are a
lot of people we want to avoid infecting
others thank you
thank you very much
as you know the Prime Minister will be
updating you later this morning on our
work to help Canadians in Atlantic
Canada and in Quebec in the aftermath of
hurricane Fiona
throughout this pandemic our government
has been focused on the advice of our
Public Health Experts of doctors with
one objective in mind keeping Canadians
healthy and safe
as the pandemic evolves so do our Public
Health measures
Canadians have stepped forward to get
vaccinated
the situation in Canada has greatly
improved but there are challenges that
remain and we have to continue to be
vigilant we have to follow Dr Dan and Dr
news and their team's recommendations
but we feel now that we can change our
Approach at the international borders at
this time my colleague the minister of
health
will be able to give you more details
about that you have the floor
good morning everyone everyone
thank you Dominique for these remarks
I want to also thank my colleagues
ministers
Mendocino and Dr new for being present
with us this morning in the past and as
Dr renew just reminded us we were
and we are in a much better position
today than we were in 2020. that is in
large part due to vaccination efforts of
Canadians and to the observance of
Public Health measures since the
outbreak of the pandemic
back in 2020 our government Rich reacted
quickly to the arrival of covid-19 and
we did not hesitate to commit Direct
Federal funding to protect Canadians
which included six billion dollars for
PPE and medical equipment 15 billion
dollars for vaccines and Therapeutics
five billion dollars for Rapid tests and
testing overall 13 billion dollars in
other public health support for a total
of close to 75 billion dollars in
protecting the health and safety of
Canadians
these Investments allowed Canadians to
access widely the tools needed to help
slow the spread of covid-19 including
the vaccines and treatments needed to
keep people from getting seriously ill
more than 85 percent of Canadians have
received at least two doses of vaccines
all Canadians age six months and older
now have access to a safe and efficient
vaccine
further fall booster vaccine campaigns
had begun across the country which for
which will further increase protection
modernas you bivalent vaccine which
specifically targets Omicron is now
offered to all Canadians adults
everywhere in the country
another good news is that 40 percent of
Canadians say they want to receive a
booster dose this fall and another 40
are considering it
this is crucial
modeling by the public health agency of
Canada indicates for instance that if
Canada were to increase its rate of
third doses from 60 to 90 percent
then it would also Reduce by 90 the
number of hospitalizations that we would
otherwise see later this fall or early
next year
again it is important that we stay up to
date with our vaccination and get the
booster shops that we are eligible to
and protect themselves and those around
us
as Dr new said immunity Fades over time
and the booster shot brings it back up
immunity is like a phone battery after
some time it needs to be recharged
so folks it's been more than six months
since your last dose it's time to
recharge your battery and get a booster
shot
High vaccination rates and Canadian
strong adherence to Public Health
measures have helped push us to an
inviable position
a recent study published by the Journal
of the Canadian Medical Association
reviewed Canada's covid-19 response
against a group of 10 comparable
countries like Belgium France Germany
the United States and Italy
the study found that most other
countries had two to three times
Canada's number of infections per capita
our death rate was also the second
lowest of the group behind only Japan
further to that the modeling recently
published by P hack suggests that
without Public Health measures or
vaccination Canada could have seen up to
2 million hospitalizations and 800 000
deaths since the start of covet 19.
that contrasts sharply to the much lower
150
000 hospitalizations and 40 000 deaths
we have seen so far
15 times fewer hospitalizations and 20
times fewer deaths that is the outcome
of Canadians having made the right
choices during the pandemic
allow me now to deal with border
measures
the ordering Council for that expires
September 30th these emergency measures
were put in place to reduce the risk of
bringing in or transmitting covid-19 and
it's the new variants
thought was always founded on Prudence
carefulness
situation abroad and others
today based on the data accumulated over
the last few weeks we are announcing
that the government of Canada will not
renew the ordering Council that expires
on September 30th and we'll move all
covid-19 order requirements for all
travelers entering Canada this includes
the removal of all federal testing
quarantines isolation environments as
well as the mandatory submission of
health information in the arrivekan
accumulated over the last few weeks and
months we are announcing that the
government of Canada will not renew the
order in council that expires on
September the 30th and will therefore
remove all corvid19 border requirements
for all travelers entering Canada
this includes the removal of all federal
testing quarantine and isolation
requirements as well as the mandatory
submission of health information in a
rifcon
the government of Canada will maintain
the ability to re-establish certain
border measures should they be required
in the future to protect Canadians from
the importation of new variants of
concern
or other emerging Public Health
throughout Canada will maintain the
ability to re-establish certain border
measures should they be required in the
future to protect Canadians from the
importation of new variants of concern
or other emerging Public Health threats
cases and its variant no longer
influenced in a significant way of the
evolution of the pandemic in Canada
higher level of cases of
hospitalizations in Canada are largely
explained by the domestic transmission
of the virus and the rate of vaccination
today allow me to say that Dr Mona Nemer
the chief Scientific Advisor has set up
a working group on a long covet or
post-covert syndrome as it is also known
the group will make a report this fall
and it will set up a framework to combat
long covered
and the best way is to keep your shots
up to date Canada has always acted
prudently with respect to covert 19.
Prudence will continue to guide our
actions as a government overcoming
months we see things will be critical
because we're all moving indoors and
there will be more respiratory
influences including covert winter we do
expect an increase on covid-19 cases and
other respiratory viruses
but by keeping our vaccine Nations up to
date and by being careful for example
wearing masks in certain circumstances
we will continue to continue to protect
our health the health of those close to
us and the health of everyone else our
workers and every everyone in general
our workers will continue and the
government of Canada will continue to do
what it must to protect the health of
Canadians I want to have a bank and
public health and agency all of the
officers who've worked so hard the land
borders at the air borders to protect
the health of everyone here in Canada to
minister Al gabra Omar
come on
thank you John Eve uh good morning
everyone bonjouratus I'd like to begin
by acknowledging that I am doing this
announcement virtually for Montreal
which has traditionally been a place of
exchange and meetings for several First
Nations
I also I want to start by saying a few
words about uh hurricane Fiona which hit
Eastern Quebec and the Atlantic region
last weekend my thoughts are with all
those who have been affected
Transport Canada is working with the
other departments involved and our
partners to support local communities
and assess the impact on our
transportation infrastructure
back to today's announcement we've
always maintained that the Extraordinary
Measures we introduced at our borders
and on airplanes trains and Boats were
temporary and that where we would adjust
them as situation changes
So today we're doing just that as my
colleague Minister Duplo just said
starting on October 1st we are removing
covid-19 measures that remain at the
border the factors that allow us to
remove these border measures also allow
me to announce that Transport Canada is
removing existing travel requirements
this means that as of October 1st
Travelers will no longer be required to
undergo health checks for travel on air
and rail or wear masks on planes and
trains
or international flights to Canada
airlines will no longer need to review
the vaccination status of foreign
Nationals
confirmed Travelers have submitted the
required information in arrivecan or
ensure compliance with the pre-entry
testing requirements
similar changes will also apply to
passengers traveling by Crews
passengers and Crews on board cruise
ships will no longer be subject to
vaccine requirements or testing before
they board a vessel
Transport Canada will continue to
provide guidance to help Crews ship
operators establish health and safety
protections
and while wearing a mask on a plane or
train will no longer be mandatory we
strongly encourage travelers to continue
doing so
thank everyone in the travel industry
for their hard work to implement these
policies over the past couple of years
it's not been easy but everyone Rose to
the occasion
industry
thank you to the industry we're able to
do this because tens of millions of
Canadians rolled up their sleeves and
got vaccinated
we've all worked together to follow the
guidelines get vaccinated and protect
one another and now we're taking another
step to returning to the normal travel
that connects families workers in our
communities Maxi thank you and now I'd
like to pass the mic to my colleague
minister medicino
good morning and let me Begin by
attributing myself to colleagues
comments about hurricane Fiona and
especially to those who have been
impacted by it the federal government is
working around the clock to provide
whatever support that we can for them
and in the meantime obviously our
thoughts are with them and as you heard
Minister LeBlanc said say more
information will be coming this morning
we moved quickly and decisively to take
action at the border and protect
Canadians in the early days of the
pandemic this meant closing our borders
and strict quarantines
as the situation evolved and improved
thanks to a world-leading vaccination
effort so has traveled with measures in
place to ensure that it happens
responsibly and safely
over the past year business tourism and
visitors have all returned to our Shores
in strong numbers and Canadians are
traveling again
over 38 million entries in total year to
date in 2022 which is more than double
the total number of Travelers we saw in
all of 2021
and this is great news for the economy
for trade for jobs and for personal
travel
and we want to keep that momentum going
So today we're taking another
significant step
as of October 1st 2022 Travelers
entering Canada will no longer be
required to use arrivecan in any mode of
travel air land or sea
this decision is as a result of the
removal of all covid related Health
measures at our borders
going forward use of arrive can will be
optional allowing Travelers who so
choose to submit their customs
declaration in advance at major airports
has been linked to mandatory health
information including vaccination status
that Travelers have submitted when
entering Canada
arrivecan will now become voluntary for
those who want to save time at airports
by uploading documents in advance
while we are moving out of the worst
phase of the pandemic we are making eggs
to accelerate the movement of people who
choose
vacation and that will allow our agents
and our border agents to concentrate on
those Travelers who may well present a
higher risk declaration feature is
already available at Toronto Pearson
Vancouver and Montreal Trudeau airports
in fact one-third of Travelers are
currently taking advantage of it in the
coming months we'll expand this option
to be available at Calgary Edmonton
Toronto City Winnipeg Halifax Quebec
City and Ottawa airports
are continuation the agency pledges to
continue this information this
application by adding information to it
that will be useful for travelers during
the pandemic Canada has modernized its
borders to make everybody's experience
more efficient and agreeable and quicker
a crossing the border more efficient
while never compromising the health and
safety and security of Canadians
I want to thank our cbsa officers for
everything they've done over the past
two and a half years
thanks to your excellent work you have
been facilitating
our economy and protecting our health
thanks to you we've emerged from this
pandemic stronger than ever and indeed
that is one of the main reasons why
we've been able to take this important
decision today and with that I will now
pass the mic over to minister Fortier
merci thank you Minister Mendicino
bombat
thank you for being with us today the
pandemic the federal government has
listened to doctors and science experts
to make sound decisions and focus on
protecting Canadians
it's not politicians who got us here
today it's Canadians who rolled up their
sleeves to get vaccinated you did your
part you got Canada to a better place
with high vaccination rates and lower
hospitalization rates and wildly
available vaccine boosters rapid tests
and treatments
were always considered as being
temporary like measures that were
introduced at the time in the public
service but it has allowed our workers
to continue working and has protected
our communities and all Canadians
requirement last spring for public
servants was based on the latest
scientific evidence and we will continue
to follow Health Canada's advice to
protect health and safety in our
workplace
vaccination is the most efficient and
effective way of protecting all of us
our economy and our country we hope that
you will keep your vaccinations
that you will stay home if you get
covered and that you continue to be
masked if necessary take your questions
we can move into the question period now
thank you we have quite a few questions
so I appreciate if you can answer them
all of course time is running and I'm
told that 9 30 is a hard or deadline so
uh we will start with uh the questions
on the floor uh if you are on Zoom
please raise your hand with the raise
hand function now so we could take them
after see the function if you are on
Zoom you can use the raised hand
function and we will go to zoom after we
take a few questions here in the room I
was man from a canyon press
there's um I want to start by asking you
about the quarantine act covid-19 cases
the quarantine act would still apply to
them can you please explain what advice
you have for travelers and what that
will mean for people who are arriving in
the country who may have covet or may
have coveted symptoms
oh thank you for the question and um the
uh as you as you heard the older in
Council expires on September 30th it
will not be renewed which means that we
come back to the um earlier rules around
quarantine and and Border measures
border agents and public health
officials have the ability to
keep screening people and advise them on
the right things to do if they happen to
be infected with covid-19 or other
diseases and and in a can in the case of
covid-19 if people enter Canada and find
out that they have been infected with
covid-19 then they will need to follow
local public health measures
thank you um you also mentioned Minister
that you sort of reserve the right to
bring border measures back under certain
conditions can you speak about what kind
of Border measures you would consider
reinstating and under what conditions
uh two things on that the first one is
that the absolute first responsibility
of a government is protect is to protect
the safety of its citizens that is
non-negotiable everything that needs to
be done in the context of Public Health
or Public Safety emergencies to protect
the safety of people needs to be done by
a responsible government the second
thing is that we have learned over the
last
two years and a half the type of
measures that can work and type of
measures that do work but need to be had
to come to an end and as we are
announcing today and we will therefore
leave open all possible options when it
comes to protecting the safety of
Canadians in the world in a covid-19
world which in particular we know has
been generating all sorts of surprises
over the last uh two years and a half so
we need to be prepared we'll be prepared
obviously we have no hope to reintroduce
some some of these measures but if we
need to to protect the safety of
Canadians we will have to
foreign
[Music]
is since 2019. if you go into the
hospitals there were 25 between 25 and
30 000 people who were hospitalized with
covert and that is before omicronics and
there was a unfortunately a very serious
uh blow
Canadians
hospitalized and also with respect to
border measures we notice that the
importation of variants of the new covet
it didn't really have an effect on the
evolution of the pandemic in coming
weeks and months is really going to be
explained and influenced by domestic
internal transmission within the country
itself that's why Dr news said like uh
all doctors and scientists have been
saying for some months is that the
accent to the stress should be placed on
vaccinations
will allow us to get through the coming
months which will be critical and we are
all here today to encourage Canadians to
continue to make good choices get the
bivalence the vaccination which is more
efficient and even more efficient
against covid-19 in particular but
because it and it's uh variants
but also to protect themselves
against transmission
because covid-19 does continue to
generate and be transmissible
in our families if I could just allow if
you would allow me to add to what jaive
said not very long ago conservatives
said that Canadians wouldn't have any
vaccination before
these vaccines literally saved thousands
of lives in Canada we don't read that as
responsible leadership in Canada
Science And
scientists we won't listen to this
irresponsible
well if there is talk about the wave
people are going back indoors and the
virus will circulate even more why did
you take away the mask mandate which is
particularly effective and now we're
going back indoors enclosed
circumstances
might add a bit more to the
science-based aspect of the answer I'm
going
[Music]
[Music]
for airline companies for example to
apply uh mandatory masking because of
the air the crew has to face
difficulties when dealing with them
hard negative attitudes of some
passengers they make the life life very
difficult for uh Airline crew but
as has been said there is a lot of
easier Transmission in certain
environments Dr new from the scientific
perspective perhaps could validate what
I have just said that as to masking
continuing to be effective yes Mr
Minister I can see science is clear
wearing a mask is clearly a means of
personal protection that is extremely
effective but also it protects other
people in terms of transmission of the
virus the changes that it is no longer
obligatory it's not mandatory it is
something that Canadians can choose
Canadians will make an enlightened
decision about this because for me I
think it's very clear that you know
in a context
the context is very crowded and where
there is poor ventilation uh it would be
advisable to continue to wear a mask
Oliver CTV
do you like to respond in English before
I ask my question is that okay yeah
um yes please
now as you heard from Dr new
wearing a mask is still a very efficient
way not only to protect ourselves but
protect others around us and the strong
recommendation that b hack is making is
for passengers on trains and on on on on
on planes and I think the Minnesota
gabra I'm speaking on behalf of Omar but
I think on our what I'm saying it aligns
with what you also are saying is that
this should still be a a a a a
relatively easy measure to take to
protect against uh covid-19 infecting
ourselves or infecting others this being
said we're moving away from a coercive
environment which is has created
um pressures and difficulties for air
air air
Travelers and air uh workers in
particular air workers have faced over
the last few weeks we have heard from
the industry
difficulties in in making that
coercive measure being followed by by
all travelers so we believe that most
Travelers will continue to wear those
masks but there will be some Travelers
who will choose not to do so and that's
all right thank you very much my
question is going to be for Dr new as
well as you Minister Duke Lowe last week
the U.S president was quoted as saying
quote the pandemic is over today the
federal government is removing the last
of the covid-19 restrictions do you
agree with his assessment
and that's a fair question the answer is
that if anyone has doubts as to whether
covid-19 still exists I would invite
that person to visit the hospital
anywhere in Canada we have between four
and five thousand people hospitalized
every day with covid-19 that puts a very
heavy burden on how hospitalized on a
hospital system it's close to 10 percent
of Hospital capacity which is currently
used for
looking after people we've called it 19.
we also know that healthcare workers are
very tired they are exhausted they have
left in large numbers and worryingly
many of them
think of leaving in even larger numbers
over the next months in Canada we need
to care for our health care workers if
we want them to care for us so we need
to protect ourselves and to protect
others by being vaccinated against the
covid-19 taking advantage of this great
new formulation for which we were one of
the first countries in the world to have
access to and it's available everywhere
in Canada and we know that Canadians
have done extremely well with two doses
we need to do and we want to do equally
well with being up to date in terms of
vaccination so I invite everyone every
Canadian listening to us know to do as
well as we've done with with two doses
and if we succeed in doing this we'll
reduce very significantly the burden on
a hospital and hospitals and importantly
on health care workers leading to the
end of the fall and early winter
it's gonna come up for me personally
what I would say is that I think we're
past what we call the acute phase of the
pandemic but certainly the pandemic's
not over you know it'll be uh obviously
the virus with us for quite some time
and I think that we need to continue to
uh you know manage and and as the as the
virus continues to evolve I think we're
we should be optimistic I think uh the
director journal the who also had a very
optimistic message you know sort of the
end is in sight but we can't actually
stay on you know you can use all the
analogies you want you know take your
foot off the gas pedal or you know as a
marathon if you see the Finishing Line
you don't stop you keep running even
faster so I think we want to be
optimistic but all of the tools at our
disposal we need to continue to push
hard you know keep our vaccine coverage
rates High you know keep up with here
your vaccination uh continue to wear you
know I would say I'm asking in certain
contexts certainly if you're in a indoor
spaces uh with uh poor ventilation if
you're in crowded places and I think as
people go out I I recognize and all of
us including myself we want to go out
and sort of have those context I think
people just need to be I think as well
thoughtful about the choices they make
as the uh I want to go out and and
reconnect with friends and family
and my follow-up question goes to that
as well you just mentioned that there
are still thousands of people
hospitalized that uh Mr new you to Dr
new you talked about in your opening
remarks that cases look like they're
climbing so given all of these
um why remove these measures right now
why not just keep them until this fall
wave and potentially winter wave as Dr
new had kind of hinted at is over
and the reason as I mentioned earlier is
because over the last few weeks and
months we have seen with the data that
we have been able to collect that the
contribution of the importation of cases
and variants into Canada that
contribution to the epidemiology and to
the evolution of the APD epidemiology is
minor it's insignificant with the what
explains covid-19 now and what we'll
explain covid-19 in the next few weeks
is a domestic situation that's where we
need to focus our efforts and that's why
as we are doing today we are encouraging
Canadians to keep making the right
choices those choices have saved the
lives of hundreds of thousands of people
in Canada one estimate is about 200 000
lives have been saved in Canada because
of vaccination we would have seen 40
times the num of 20 times sorry the
number of deaths if Canadians hadn't
followed Public Health measures and
hadn't had not been vaccinated in so
high numbers so these are the right
choices that people made over the last
two years and a half we want to continue
making those right choices and those
choices are essentially
driven and observed internally within
Canada
Mercy uh thank you David again before I
leave you the mic I just remind you to
keep their answers and the questions
short because we have many questions and
really little time David uh question
from minister medicino
um just to wonder if you speak to the
operational complexity of taking all
these measures off we saw a lot of
hiccups with our travel system as new
measures were introduced we saw lots of
hiccups when people started traveling
again when these come off is this going
to go smoothly do we need more funding
more people just wondering about that
well that is uh certainly the goal and
uh one of the things that we've done is
worked very closely with colleagues
across various line Ministries including
uh minister duclow at public health and
Minister Al gabra at transportation to
ensure that as we make modifications to
our policies whether it's through
changes to the oic's or to our policies
that we are aligning that to
operationalization uh as it relates to
our platforms and training
um I think to be direct about it now
that arrive cam will be optional that
will actually be a more straightforward
change because it will be at the choice
of the traveler to use that technology
and all other restrictions will be
lifted so in a way I think the update to
our Frontline cbsa officers will be more
straightforward that way
and just maybe just you personally will
you continue to use arrive candle you
choose to be an arrive can user for your
travel well I've uploaded it and you
know I know that there's various uh
anecdotes out there some people who were
very frustrated and others who have said
that their experience was actually quite
smooth and I do think that um you know
consistent with the principle that we've
used uh in uh using technology on a go
forward I think it's important that we
are always leveraging new Innovations so
that traveler experience can be smooth
and effective and for those Canadian
Travelers and for those Travelers abroad
who do choose to use this application
will use their experience to continue to
improve that platform because ultimately
we won't be able people people to be
able to travel smoothly and effectively
and efficiently CBC
thank you I wonder how concerned you are
about mixed messaging to Canadians on
the pandemic being over or not I see
only Dr Howard knew wearing a mask today
and he's the only person here who's not
an elected official you talked about
you know Rising case counts at the same
time Minister du Chloe you're saying the
pandemic is not over and anyone who
thinks it is should walk into a hospital
so what are Canadians to take away from
how careful you're telling them to be
right now by lifting these measures
a couple of messages and my colleagues
might want to to add first we making
those decisions we are mindful of the uh
the challenges and the costs that border
communities have been facing over the
last few weeks and months it's been hard
for them and
um my colleagues and all members of our
caucus have
I felt that and have listened to them
and we have therefore taken those costs
and challenges into account in making
the decision but that decision again was
driven by the evidence that we have seen
over the last few weeks and months which
is
that the transmission and the cost of
transmission of covid-19 on our
healthcare workers hospitals and
including those patients that have seen
backlogs in their surgeries and and
treatments over the next two years and a
half so these costs are now almost
entirely driven by domestic transmission
of covid-19 that's where we need to
invest our energies and that's that's
why therefore Public Health measures as
we all know now and being up to date in
terms of vaccination that's why that
matters so much if you haven't if if we
haven't had a
covid-19 vaccine in the last six months
we need to get one it's like a phone
battery our battery is now almost dead
we need to recharge that battery and to
be up to date in terms of vaccination
that's the key key action which
individually we can take it comes with
no cost all of those vaccines are
distributed free of charge by the
federal government no cost to anyone and
no cost to provinces and territories it
takes a little time no
and it obviously requires you know
moving to a place so it's it's not
completely free of cost but it's very
cheap time wise and absolutely cheap
from a cost perspective however it makes
a big impact on the pandemic a
hospitalization cost on average twenty
three thousand dollars when it's related
to Kobe 19. that's a lot of cost so if
we can collectively keep doing the right
thing and protect each other we are
going to keep doing collectively very
well compared to many other countries
follow-up review
just wondering about arrive can and its
continued use even as optional what
assurances can you provide Canadians
about their their private data remaining
in safe hands
especially for the ones who decide to
get rid of it now well the most
Assurance I can provide them is that we
will continue to abide by the law
including their rights under the charter
and we work very closely with the
Privacy commissioner to ensure that not
only arrive can but all of our platforms
and our policies are done in a way that
respects privacy rights but also is is
able to be that information is able to
be used in a way that protects the
health and safety of Canadians
I am told that we have time for perhaps
one last question I'm go I'm going to
zoom to Ryan to milti from National Post
foreign
yeah good morning good morning ministers
um I wanted to ask it seems like based
on the leaks uh that happened last week
that this decision was made last week
I'm wondering why it took as long as it
did to actually announce it
um you know given the big impact that
this has on the border on on Travelers
on airlines on airports
um why the delay there
well I would say that no there is no
delay this is being announced in advance
of the expiry of the current OIC which
expires on September the 30th we have
made those announcements in the past in
anticipation of those days that for
which orders and console were expiring
and then maybe just as a follow-up are
you still planning to
um I guess prosecute uh people who were
issued fines for not
um using Arab can do all those fines
still stay in place
that is a decision made by the uh the
justice system and obviously independent
of uh political interference I would uh
recommend and I think we would recommend
that you direct this question to the
ministry of Justice
would you have time for one last
question ministers because it's 9 30 and
as per the norm we take at least the
same number of questions at the same
time as the the
statements so perhaps I'll go to uh
olivi
tibia
hello good morning
you said earlier
we could reintroduce other measures in
the future to protect Canadians from
other variants
specialist who said that order measures
were not efficient in
countering uh new variants so how are
you going to continue to fight against
new variants and the introduction of new
variants if that doesn't operate well
that is to say border measures
we've heard thank you we've heard on
some occasions and uh
border measures do not stop the
introduction of all variants when
variants change quickly like is the case
with Omicron throughout the country
there are many cases outside of the
country
and uh that is where
it is significant we noted some weeks
ago there was a ba1 ba 4B A5 that have
entered into Canada that are already
present in Canada though and we had
Travelers coming into Canada who
demonstrated that their infection was
very similar to those who are already
infected in Canada so we uh with respect
to the transmission of covid-19 in the
country have reached today's conclusions
over the course of last week we looked
carefully
[Music]
the situation if we look at the case of
Omicron uh in December and it can happen
that if there are new variants that
emerge the government of Canada may have
to move to protect the health and safety
of all Canadians because it really is a
social contract between government and
its citizens to protect the health and
security of its citizens that is one of
the
major responsibilities of a government
so if it has to be done we will do so
but there are other measures that could
be used in the future if the situation
required it nobody wants this to happen
okay
um
we're still in a pandemic
you're saying that you spoke of the
rates that are in hospitals it's
significant but can you say uh right now
that we are still in a pandemic even
though the virus is amongst us still uh
we have moved from acute pandemic to
another stage of pandemic uh Dr new
perhaps you could answer
in terms of defining a pandemic
yes I can tell you yeah
believe that we have moved from the
acute
level of pandemic the virus is
circulating still in Canada but
elsewhere in the world as well we will
have to continue to deal with and live
with the virus the virus is continuing
to evolve and we have to be
[Music]
are following very closely what is
happening in terms of transmission but
also with respect to what shows up in
waste water in communities within our
country we have the tools to detect if
there's a Resurgence of the virus or if
there is an emergence of a virus that is
new and of concern thank you ministers
thank you Dr news
thank you have a good day
you'll see